now you won't believe what I'm about to
tell you but they asked me just a moment
ago could you go out and as they say in
the business stretch a little bit
apparently there's a danger of the show
coming in under four hours I'm being
honest with you the fact is they have a
set here that has to be as they say in
the business struck and apparently they
didn't realize how long this was going
to take up until now I couldn't
understand that situation and then I
found out that the man in charge of
moving sets was also the former valve
operator at Three Mile Island so I don't
know whether they're ready yet I have
some sports scores I know you folks back
East will be watching the news about now
103 to 97 67 242 hockey final four to
one also I have a bulletin that just
came in from the traffic helicopter
seems an avocado truck has flipped over
in the Santa Ana freeway so you folks
going that direction I think your best
bet is to hit the Bellflower off-ramp
you off that now okay good
yeah
as you know film is not only forever in
time it's also everywhere in geography
and because of the international appeal
of Motion Pictures the Academy
recognizes the best foreign language
film every year and present that award
tonight here is one of the most
internationally acclaimed directors
Franco Zeffirelli and a young actress
star of stage screen and pants miss
Brooke Shields
I'm very glad to be presenting in the
war tonight with my current boss this
wonderful man standing next to me that's
very nice well so that you might come a
little late tomorrow morning for work
hélène 6:15 Thanks
I'd better hurry then the nominees for
Best Foreign Language Film of the year
are confidence I'm a film studio
production hungry Kagemusha
The Shadow Warrior Toho Company Limited
Kesava productions Japan the last Metro
le film de carros products young France
Moscow does not believe in tears a must
for film studio production circuit Union
and the last and the nest excuse me and
a punto elsa production spain and the
winner is the winner is soviet union
moscow does not believe in tears
three from Russia
cultural attache of us
ladies and gentlemen it's my great
honour to receive so important ever on
behalf of our film director vladimir
menshov actresses letter aleph Chava and
actress aleksey batalov Gosha I would
like to express many thanks to Academy
Motion Pictures Arts and Science thank
you very much
you